foreign
s crash the crease that was Ben
Jones trying to get a chance on
well Joshua has gotten his way to
the Vancouver bench as the puck
[Music]
but the late change coming on because of Joshua
being injured on the four check and this bounces
towards the net and as jet Wu is trying to box
out it goes off the Stick of drives off the skate
and you can see the turning it ahead from the
shelocks couldn't believe it snuck Underneath Him
Coronado dishes off rajeets can in front
Dube tried to tip that on will but they
cannot start in the way of another one rap boat
trying to move the puck had his tip tied up
here's Hannah the long shot deflected stop
rebound this door [Music] [Applause] [Music]
oh
battling in the corner just losing
control of the puck for the last moment
it squeezes out and gets to the point
and this is just thrown towards the net
and Coronado on his forehand as he's going
down is able to elevate it over shelovs
Wu couldn't get back in time to help at all
and another shot from the left point that
down to the goal line hole looking across puts
one in front and Cadre missed on that one time
attempt Noah julson stepped up to force the issue
here's Cadre again Hoover no drag move shot scores
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music] it's a power
gonna go on the Flames have a three-nothing lead
looks everybody off missed play Sharon Govich
is going to gather little bumper play and
here's where it's held and then fired past the
blocker ubered old a career here in Florida and
off here last season and they're hoping he can
do more of that for Calgary but for Vancouver
in battle with Dylan Dubin here's Cadre behind the
net coming towards the front back Anderson [Music]
dumped down behind the net and cadre's
already there julson a step behind
and shielding the puck there's the wrap around
fake and then to the backhand and this is
right upstairs and that's the far Corner
shelocks thought he had things sealed off
but the veteran Cadre goes up upstairs [Music]
that'll make it four nothing rap though pokes it
up the boards gilia solovio throws it on goal
stopped by she loves pucks underneath his Pad
it was now shoveled back towards
him by Dakota Joshua and she loves
trying to wrap on around on markstrom
in the first period perhaps the early
capitalization of that on the special teams zerry
in the box for a holding and the Canucks start
the power play to Center this silly pot coal an
opportunity to move into fifth himself this year
here's a chance obon in a glove saved by markstrom
who read that puck well from side to side and was
able to reach out and stare at with a left hand
could not sweep it ahead again and this time
it's picked up and brought ahead by atsuratsu two
teammates with him ratu in towards the net check
because he tried to get a shot away Nanny followed
up and got one on goal stopped by markstrom
six nations taking down the salmon valleys
foreign
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music]
holding
Irwin can't get a full blade on that pass
across Uber though gathers whips it and
as she lost was moving from Locker to glove
Buck went back and over his right shoulder
so he doesn't necessarily want to see players
getting banged up but that's sort of I think
what he's aiming for his guys who are hungry to
get in and hungry to win the puck and get it to
their teammates that are going to do something
with it oh there's a turnover Coronado [Music]
in front of the net with the puck julson's trying
to just buy some time with the leading stick from
Dryden hunt deflects it into the slot and
if you're a goal scorer like Coronado is
you've already got your shot picked out and it's
past the glove of shelofs and do the Congo line
to Anderson wide on Irwin centering
pass all the way back to Hannah can
he shoots he scores [Music]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause]
Noah Hannaford skated right into that Slap
Shot and it's a seventh goal for Calgary
his D partner throws it across it's off the
boards and this is a rocket over the glove
you're gonna block the shot you'd like to make
sure that you get a piece of it clemovich couldn't
let's go with a long shot stick
save by markster Moon went after
the loose Puck and then he scrambled back there's
his toughest save as he came to his right
to deny Jack stanika and get the whistle
so he gets the rest of the night off Oscar dead
skin for Calgary and we're underway in the third
period Zach sawchinko in goal for the Canucks he
took over for Archers she loves after the seventh
Calgary goal and Gilbert was helped off the ice
and it would appear that his night is done as the
Flames win control on the power equipment Coronado
who scored twice in this game now here's Racine
[Music] [Applause]
sochenko made the first save but Zary able to
pop on the rebound and Calgary on the power play
makes it eight nothing well you got to block
the puck coming towards the front of the net
and both defensemen were caught staring
and not protecting the dangerous player
he's through the legs of Irwin and
late to get there as sooner who's a
forward who have to come all the way down
because jet Wu was caught out too high
James Center and shoots the puck
in [Applause] Coronado in a battle
with Jack raproll and Coronado comes up with
the puck and they score and Jones [Applause]
picks up a helper on this one Rathbone was
battling but Coronado after taking a hook
is able to come up with the puck and ratu
didn't want to come all the way down from
the Winger position because that's
not really his guide dries is late
and Jones surprises sachenko before
the glove gets up the red light goes on
here's Coronado turning with a buck
Hannaford the bottom of Passenger was
each kill double claps now Coronado
shoots he scores [Applause] [Music]
our plan expired but it's a hat-trick goal
for Coronado the glove off the goaltender in
time here Coronado will watch his feet two-step
as rozichka puts it to the middle it's bumped
across and the right hand shot running out of
an angle gets it up past the glove of sachenko
blocks for the home fans to cheer
for and this one is Jason markster
that Oscar dance [Music] a couple of
goals for Jonathan huberto as well